un bosquet tout en illusions en son
centre jean cotelle il pas un arbre en
plomb irréel un ensemble le vrai le faux
se côtoient
ce bosquet du marais aujourd'hui disparu
donc c'est un témoignage très
intéressant de ses bosquets de je dirais
du appartenant au versailles baroque
dire le premier versailles celui de
madame de montespan et d'ailleurs il est
dit que ses bosquets à l'origine madame
de montespan l'avait imaginé c'est l'un
des 21 tableaux de jean cantel
rassemblés par le château de versailles
l'artiste du roi aimé peindre jardin et
mythologie des tableaux restaurés
pendant 5 à 6 ans dont 16 de manière
fondamentale exposé aujourd'hui dans
l'un des lieux les plus prestigieux du
trianon la galerie des quotas
c'est un lieu ouvert sur l'extérieur par
des fenêtres du côté des parterres et du
cas du côté des jeux du jardin des
sources
c'est un lieu où la lumière pénètre est
en quelque sorte les tableaux de
bosquets que vous voyez ici reflète cet
extérieur le roi aimait se promener dans
ses jardins y faire des haltes et de
nouveau à l'intérieur il se repose
devant ses bosquets jean cotten des
jardins et des dieux se vit aussi à
l'extérieur le miniaturiste a inspiré
les jardiniers du château une longue
étude de ce tableau pour recréer la
volonté du peintre plus d'une vingtaine
de variétés de plantes donne vie ce
tableau
près d'une trentaine d'oeuvres font
revivre l artiste oubliées comme une
renaissance
[Musique]